people are very stressed out about the
sex robots I have yet to hear an
argument against them that I buy
everyone's like aren't you worried
they're gonna replace human women get
the fuck out of here one of my own
girlfriends was like aren't you worried
they're gonna replace us if you're
worried about being replaced by a giant
piece of plastic you're not bringing
that much to the table in the first
place though I need you to watch a TED
talk anyway also they're not gonna
replace human women that's an insulting
argument to women if anything they will
replace blowup dolls which by the way I
love that that was a product guys were
fucking rafts with eyelashes and that
wasn't freaking anybody out this is
where we draw the line yeah yeah that's
so weird to me that everyone's so
fascinated about how bad the sex robots
will be for women cuz you know they're
making male sex robots too right where
are you guys sweatin I mean look if we
get replaced by the female sex robot
it'll be a bummer but like we'll be fine
what the fuck are you guys gonna do if
you get replaced by the male sex robots
who's gonna force you to go to the
doctor you'll all die of sinus
infections you don't even know where the
frickin Forks are and you'll die
I know there are some problems I know
they need to make some tweaks to the
robots I understand that cuz I've seen
them in person first of all they're
gorgeous this is a bad idea I'm a very
jealous person I do not want to Scarlett
Johansson asked looking robot in my
house I'll tell you this right now
if they make the robots gorgeous there
will be a war between human women and
robot women and I swear to god we will
freakin win
[Applause]